growing up what were the things that you
were not good at
i think growing up i'd always been good
at making plans and a plan that would
work so if i had like a homework
assignment i was good at figuring out
all right if i wrote this many pages for
this essay by this point it will be
done and i'll be good i was always good
at making those plans i was not always
great at
executing them so it's like oh i have
this great plan and then
i wouldn't follow it and i'd have to
like write the whole thing the night
before and it wasn't that great
so i think i've always been more
interested in
creating that thing than actually doing
it necessarily which is maybe why i got
into screenwriting because perhaps i'm
more interested
in writing the story and then letting
other people just execute
the creation of it because it's to me
the creative work
i've already gotten the fulfillment out
of it what i need
i think that'd be it when did you start
calling yourself a writer
i think i started calling myself a
writer
about three years ago probably when i
moved to los angeles
i started taking it seriously
and even then i think i was a little bit
hesitant to call myself a writer
i think i still am a little bit but
i had written for a few years before
when i was living in
atlanta but never seriously ever
professionally
and it wasn't till i made the move that
i decided like okay i'm
i'm a writer this is what i'm doing
why were you hesitant was it because it
was too easy to be
this like i had to use the cliche of the
la like multi-hyphenate you know where
but
sometimes that that turns people off
because then they're like well well
if you do all these things what are you
good at so were you afraid to do
i think it was that i was afraid to call
myself something that i wasn't
actually doing professionally and what i
mean professionally i mean getting
paid to do so i
wouldn't call myself a writer because no
one was paying me to write
and so even though i was writing it just
felt weird to say oh i'm a writer
because i think when people
say when people ask you what do you do i
always i guess internalize that is what
do you
what is your career what do you get paid
to do and i wasn't getting paid to write
yet
so i still wouldn't call myself a writer
even though
almost every morning i was writing i
just didn't feel like i had earned it
yet because no one
had paid me for it and i think that's
why sometimes i still feel a little bit
hesitant because if i'm not
on a job or doing anything then i'm like
well am i a writer i don't
not not right now so wow that's really
interesting because i think so many
people
especially being around entertainment
and it sounds like you've been around
entertainers all your life
they they're always putting that label
on
maybe even before it's even warranted so
it's interesting that you you were
hesitant to do that
yeah i think i was just
i don't know maybe there's also a fear
of being put in a box
even if it's a box that i realize now i
want to be in it just felt
weird to say oh i'm a writer because
maybe it meant to me
that i'm not anything else
and i didn't feel like that was accurate
you know i'm just i'm
i'm david and i write but i also i love
to sail and i love magic and so like all
these other things and it's like but i'm
not a sailor i'm not a magician
so i it just felt weird to be like oh i
am a writer like that's the box i'm in
even though of all the different boxes
of all the stuff i'm interested in
that's what i'm most fulfilled by
when was the first time you saw someone
perform magic
i don't i don't remember the first time
i saw someone perform magical my
my dad is a big magic fan of watching it
he has no interest in doing it but he
he loves it so we were on a family
vacation in texas
and there was basically a texan version
of the magic castle here in la and so my
dad got tickets for the whole family and
we went
and we're going in and out of these
different rooms seeing different
magicians close up
and bigger illusions on stages and all
sorts of stuff
and i think that just stuck with me and
so
i go to the magic castle every now and
then
and i'll be taking magic classes in a
few months
and it's just always been something that
interests me but
i have no sort of professional
aspirations it's like as a purely as a
hobby
when did the outside world validate your
writing and
what did that mean to you i think the
first time the outside world
validated my writing
was when i was living in atlanta
and i wrote something i didn't really
know
what it was yet what i was doing and i
just passed it to some
friends at the the company i was working
for
none of whom were professional
screenwriters or any
even had an interest in in the in story
or the craft or anything
but one responded one of my friends
responded really
strongly he said this is really good
this is
really good i think that the story could
be better but this shows that
you're a really good writer and
that was the first time i think
the way he said it i felt like there was
something that he was resonating with
in the writing and not just saying oh
you're good at this thing i
i can see it and you're good it felt
like to me
he was actually moved by parts of it
it wasn't great yet and he told me that
but there was some there was something
in there that he responded to and so
seeing that reaction in someone
from something i had actually written
the full
screenplay for was the first time i
think
i felt i could maybe do this
what about the first time you were paid
for writing
how did that feel and how long did it
take you
up into that point the first time i was
paid
for writing i felt like all of a sudden
i had all this
free time on my hands because before i
had always
been doing other work to get paid and
then i was writing
so the first time i didn't have to do
all that other work and i just focused
on the writing i could spend
more time writing but i still had all
this free time
that i didn't know what to do with and i
always i felt guilty for not
spending it writing and so it sort of
felt like is this what it's like should
i what should i be doing with my time
because i didn't quite know what to do i
didn't have to go
looking for other jobs right away near
the end of the project i had to start
thinking okay what's next i gotta go
make sure there's work
for me somewhere after this this job is
up
but it was incredibly freeing on the one
hand but also
pretty scary on the other because now it
was this totally new
lifestyle during those weeks that i
didn't know
i hadn't been used to and i didn't know
what to do about it
so did you ask anybody like did you
check in with any other people that had
been in your shoes before and say like
i'm having this is
this feels different um i didn't
i didn't really check in with anyone
because i didn't it was while i was in
atlanta at the time and
the the people i knew were not
necessarily screenwriters and i had kind
of
sort of as a fluke almost tripped into
this screenwriting opportunity that i
got paid to do
and so i didn't know i had no clue what
to do and i didn't even know who to
reach out for
and how did you how did you accidentally
get involved in that
you know georgia screenwriting project
um
i the the company i was working for at
the time which was a video production
company and we had done a few feature
films and a couple short films
and i had pitched them on
on making a movie and
one of their friends had just kind of a
crazy life story
and he was in the middle of it and
my boss and him were talking one time
and they're like we could make a movie
out of this and so then they came to me
and they're like i think we're going to
maybe try to write a movie out of this
do you want to write it
you don't have to worry about editing or
doing some of your other
tasks you'll just focus on writing and i
said yeah of course yeah
absolutely and so i started doing it and
i just then i didn't know what what to
do with myself
so i was learning basically how to
screen write
professionally um
on the job i'd studied it
and i had written my own work but i'd
never been paid to it so all
the other things that come with writing
a screenplay
that are not related to the craft was
totally new to me but i was now getting
paid to do it so i had to figure it out
of just how to navigate that world
you think it was easier because this was
your boss like if this had been
somebody that you never had met before
or was it actually scarier
i think it was easier i think it was an
easier job uh
not necessarily because he was my boss
but because we had a good relationship
he was he was a good friend and so
i trusted him and he trusted me and so
we were able to
do that and there was a good line of
communication when
i felt like i was struggling to make a
deadline for certain pages
or i needed more i needed to go back and
we needed to talk to this guy again
because it was his life story and so he
was really good about
managing me getting me access to him but
also pushing me and
telling me when i needed to
you know like just challenge myself a
little more maybe i didn't need that
more access maybe that was just
a way that i was afraid of going and
writing the pages he said no just go
go ahead and write and just you're on
deadline and he was really good about
that so i think
all things considered it was definitely
better for me than
not good for me did you know up until
that point that you would try to make
your living as a writer or
this opportunity just presented itself i
had thought about
seriously pursuing writing before that
first opportunity came up
and so i've been studying it i'd always
been interested in it so i've always
been reading
and reading screenplays reading books
about screenwriting
but more as just part of a larger
filmmaking
curriculum i didn't know necessarily
what i wanted to do
but it was probably in the few months
leading up to that that i thought maybe
writing is actually where
i i really want to focus where i'm most
fulfilled where i'm
decent at it and
i had perhaps just kind of been more
vocal about that at
where i was working and that's probably
why this job came up
and i was considered to write it
and so i think it was i thought about it
before writing
that project and i think writing that
project really solidified okay this is
what
i want to do and probably at that point
it got in my head that
i should move out to la if i'm going to
get serious about this
you grew up in north carolina correct
yeah
at what point did you say you would move
to la so you're living in georgia you
get this great opportunity
it sounds like the perfect thing for
someone as
a first-time screenwriting project yeah
it was great
i think from that point it was about
six months to when
i left atlanta but i wasn't actually
sure
where i was going to go because my
girlfriend
was also looking for a move to get more
serious about
her profession in performance and
writing
but we didn't know where a good fit for
both of us would be so we saved up
tons of money and we actually took about
a five month
road trip and we checked out new york we
were there for about a month my sister
lived there at the time and so we stayed
with her for a month we went to chicago
stayed with my aunt
went to l.a didn't know anyone saw a
couple
airbnbs and some some motel rentals
but basically we wanted to park in those
cities for a couple weeks so that
we could see what it would be like to
live there beyond just visiting
both as the city how we liked it and
also professionally like
what was going on and after doing the
three of them
pretty quickly la became the clear
choice
and so then we drove back to georgia
picked up all of our stuff out of a
storage unit and then
trucked it all the way back out west
that's really interesting so instead of
doing a road trip documentary
or something you just did your life was
this road trip and then
you sort of based on where you wanted to
land so to speak
yeah we checked out we went to tons of
screenings tons of theaters in
all those cities tried to go to as many
meetups as possible set up as many
meetings just over coffee with whoever
we could
just to get a sense of the community
and the industry within those cities and
where we would have the best shot
at starting off and
la was the choice that became apparent
especially for me as a
feature writer and then once we saw the
theater scene in l.a it worked out for
my girlfriend as well
where was the first place you you drove
to like
when you when you got off the five or
whatever 101
where was the first place you
destination um
the first place we stopped was west
hollywood i had a friend
it was actually my mom's best friend's
son who i had met a few times
and i asked him if we could crash on his
couch for a bit
and he led us as
way longer than we had we told him we
probably would be
be there um but right in west hollywood
wow how was the parking it was tough
that's the thing you'd a lot of people i
don't think think about you know
yeah the parking is such an issue yeah
many places i
in my budget i allow like at least two
tickets a year i just
i just figure it's got i'll mess up
somewhere
so you go back to georgia you get your
stuff you come here to la
was it more difficult than you had
initially imagined
it was not more difficult than i had
imagined
moving to la but it was difficult
i saved up and i was ready to
dig in and i'd hoped
that maybe i would had been over
prepared
but i felt like i was prepared and it
was tough especially that first year
and it's not that i didn't have
successes that first year it's that it
was way more kind of
up up and down it was higher highs and
lower lows that first year
of not just screenwriting but even just
living
in a new city a big city an expensive
city
and so i got here
immediately started looking for
part-time work just wherever i could get
it
started looking for internships wherever
i could i ended up with
three internships at one point
i was going into i was assisting at a
talent agency
two days a week i was remotely reading
scripts for a production company and
then as soon as that one ended i got
into
reading scripts for a management company
here in la
and so it's really busy all of course
unpaid so i'm doing my part-time work as
well
and i'm trying to write my own material
at the same time and so
it was a real grind at first and
the second year got easier but
just as the there weren't as many lower
lows or higher highs but it was still
that little bit of a grind and i think i
let the pedal off a little bit i thought
i had kind of
oh i figured this out and i think
ellie started pushing back a little bit
as well
and i felt it and so now after
three just about three whole years here
i feel like okay i think i figured out
at least how to live here now let's
figure out how to screen right here
oh wow that's interesting okay what was
the most
difficult thing to get used to in terms
of living in la and
then also what's the most difficult in
terms of looking for screenwriting work
in terms of living in la the most
difficult thing for me was definitely
the traffic and the
timing of things i am a planner so i'm
always
i definitely want to be there on time
for whatever meaning whatever thing i
have going on
and not only was i holding myself for
that snare but also other people so i
the traffic i knew would be really bad
and so i would leave
excessively early and get to a coffee
meeting for someone to to meet with over
a project there's another writer to ask
for advice
and i would be upset when they were late
even if it was like five or ten minutes
late like
irrationally upset and so it was a
difficult learning curve for me to sort
of learn to let that
go and just people are going to be
either really late or really early
because traffic is just so
erratic here and you can never tell
where it's going to be backed up
and for how long so once i started just
getting in the habit of making sure that
i always had
a new book on my kindle or my phone or
something i always had something to do
and something to work on
it got a lot easier for me to sort of
hang out and wait for people to meet
and also i realized how great people
were
about when i was running late how they
were just they were cool with it i was
like well i need to learn how to be cool
about it too
yeah i remember for me coming here as
well that was a lesson someone had to
sit me down and
talk to me about because i would hold
myself to that standard i would beat
myself up if i was like five minutes
late
and then the same for someone else and
so i
that was a tough one for me as well yeah
yeah because i think if you're
conscientious
when someone else isn't it's like you're
like whoa you know
i think that that was a tough one for me
yeah well i would feel
i would feel terrible if i was running
late and
then when i would finally get there the
other person would just
be like yeah no big deal traffic i was
like oh
i need to learn how to be like that i
mean i need to be as cool about it
as you are when you're the one running
late right that's
because you know i felt taken care of
and
i wanted to make sure that i was taking
care of people too and they
ran into traffic sure and then there's
just people that are chronically late
all the time
they just use that as an excuse but well
the great thing about la is that it's
the permanent excuse
you can just always just say traffic
right yeah exactly
and it's a great time to to give
yourself time to do something
if you're super early for things because
sometimes you'll you'll surprise
yourself and you'll be like 45 minutes
early for something
i'm assuming i'm sorry yeah that happens
to me too
and and then you're just sitting there
and you have all this time
and you can do other things well what i
started doing is when i would
anytime i'd have a meeting i would just
go there hours early and then i would
just work
if i had the time i would just get there
super early so i don't have to worry
about it and now all that time between
when i would drive and meeting someone i
would just work there
instead of working at home or a coffee
shop i would just go work at a coffee
shop i was about to meet them at that
way i'm just there
and i can literally just work right up
until whenever they show up whether
they're early late right on time
i can get my work done so it sounds like
the most difficult part of
just the living arrangements in la is
the traffic and wanting to be on time
for people and that's understandable
that's commendable
what about the most difficult time in
getting acclimated to finding
screenwriting work
um because there's also a looseness
the way things are done here too in
terms of yeah and everyone's nice and
i never hear from you yeah um
i don't know if i'm actually if i'm
really like sort of qualified to answer
that question i feel like i'm still
trying to figure out how to get
screenwriting work
i feel like the screenwriting work i've
gotten
is mostly through
friends or friends of friends i have yet
to figure out how to just
secure that job find that job get it and
start working both of the
jobs i've had since i've moved here it
was not
planned to be a job it was a friend
saying hey i have a friend out in la who
actually directs films you guys should
grab coffee
just to catch up see what they're up to
and we have coffee we end up talking and
then a few days later
i get the call hey would you actually
want to write my screenplay but there
was never any sort of oh i'm going in to
pitch on this thing
or i'm going to meet with his director
because he's looking for a screenwriter
there was never any of that in any of
the jobs i've ever
gotten so i guess i'd say the most
difficult thing is figuring that out
that you won't necessarily know how your
jobs are going to come to you and
being okay with that and going
to meet people and hang out with people
and talk to people with no sense of a
job on the other end
but recognize that just through meeting
people you're gonna have more
opportunities
even if you don't necessarily know what
they are that was another conversation
someone had with me too just the
looseness of in terms of
you could nev you might yeah we should
totally connect
never hear from them and then you hear
from them like a year later and then
they have something great for you
and you were like wow they never even
returned my call that's so weird i
thought okay
i'll take it you know yeah but that's
another thing too it's like
there's not really a lot of rules and
there's no hard yes or no
yeah i think that the way this industry
works it could be
that one year ago i met someone who's
going to change my life
next year and i have no clue who that
person is but i could get a call from
someone i met
at a mixer or some sort of table read
something
and say hey that thing you said about
that project you were working on
i really dug that and my buddy is
actually doing something similar
you should talk to him and then that
ends up being a job but i have no clue
that that thing i did a year ago is
going to pay off
a year from now because that's just how
it works and it's really tough to
calculate
so i think if anything i've learned just
to not
try and calculate yeah
yeah nothing's definite yeah and that's
a hard especially if
you're a planner and i get that yeah and
i'm you can fall into the same
way that you like things to be boxes to
be checked off and so yeah that's that's
another one that's
interesting there's nothing definite no
hard yes or no
let's say someone is going on a road
trip they've decided la is the place
they want to live
they say hey can we meet for coffee and
can you give me some do's and don'ts
and how do i make roots here how do i
land work
i think that for someone moving here the
advice i would give them and give them
two pieces of advice
the first one would be don't break the
bank with
where you choose to live your day-to-day
life make sure that you're living
within your means and that your savings
which hopefully you're moving here with
you can extend as long as possible all
the considerations about where you think
you might be working where you think you
might be hanging out
if you don't know la yet then you're not
going to be able to make that decision
so
find some place that you can live and
then once you know the city after a few
years and you
are sure that you want to stay you sure
that you want to keep doing this then
you can find that neighborhood you go
that's where i want to be
and you can go there at that point
that'd be the first piece of advice the
second piece of advice
would be really to take stock
in your own network
who you can meet or who you know that
can help you meet someone
but also take stock in yourself
and where your strengths are and where
your weaknesses are
as a person as a professional and
really think about how you are going to
first navigate
the industry because everyone's
method of navigation is going to be
really different so the more you can
reflect
on yourself and think about how you can
fit in
the more success i think you'll have
when you try to do that
do you go to a lot of meetups i go to
a fair amount of meetups i guess i
co-host
uh sort of a monthly one with a friend
and doing what just
we just uh meet up and we just basically
pick a place in time
and say if you're a writer or you're
interested in writing if you know really
anyone is welcome we're writers we want
to hang out if that sounds fun to you
you can attend to you don't have to be a
writer you can just
show up and the first one got way bigger
than we thought it would be
and so as we continue to host them we
have to make sure that we're places that
have the space for it because
there's something i think really freeing
about
writers meeting up to hang out with
other writers because
i'm not necessarily going to get a job
directly from you maybe
partially through you because you know
someone or something like that but
no one feels like they're there to sell
or be sold to someone so we can just
kind of meet up and talk shop together
and commiserate about just this common
situation that we all find ourselves in
do you think it's also interesting
because so many writers well
and i'm generalizing here that they're
introverted or they're just more
they're solitary creatures just because
of the nature of what they do
so to meet other people like that
in a city that's so sort of extroverted
it's kind of refreshing
yeah i think that's also been a big part
of it and
what i always tell people at these
meetups is
never worry about talking about yourself
just approach someone
and don't even ask them about them ask
them about their project ask a writer
about
their project and they'll just start
talking to you because that's the thing
that they love
and so you can really get people to open
up by just saying hey
what are you working on right now or i
saw that thing that you wrote tell me
more about that
um and i think a lot of
the introverted writers are particularly
us feature writers
uh who tend to live a more isolated
lifestyle
are willing to open up a lot more when
you're just like okay i don't want to
talk about me i talk about my story
cool right and there's no like
qualifiers we're not like judging like
oh
what categories this person fit in just
tell me about your project i like that
that's like a safe
question yeah well it's also it's funny
because
everyone prepares their
pitches for when that executive they get
in the elevator with them
and oh you're a writer what's your
project and everyone gets all nervous
but as soon as another writer
says tell me about your project and you
know that well they're not
gonna buy your project they can't buy
your product because there's another
writer
and everyone's pitches get way better
when they're talking to someone where
there's no pressure and so you say tell
your project and they go well it's a
story about this and they get really
animated
and they give the best pitch of their
lives because it's relaxed and
they're just talking to someone else
who's just like them
that's really cool so it's just like
dinner and drinks and everybody hangs
out and just talks about their projects
and being a writer
yeah usually we try to go somewhere that
has
like snacks available but it's mostly
just like drinks and it's just sort of
like mingling in cocktails and
just hanging out cool and then on
twitter it looks like you've built a
strong community there
yeah and that's where i usually get the
word out about
whatever sort of meetups or mixers i'm
trying to
put together i should really give credit
to my friend for putting most of it
together
and he just kind of tags me and
we end up co-hosting which really means
just
we're just there as well because we're
the ones that told everyone to go meet
up at this place
at this time was that something you did
back home
or is this sort of the new david coming
here
uh though that was not something i did
back home i think if i
was left to my own devices i would
probably stay in and
read a book and i should give credit to
my girlfriend for pushing me in the past
year to be
more vocal
in my opinions about screenwriting and
the craft and also just
pay attention to the networking side of
the career
that i've chosen and it is
part of the job and it doesn't have to
be a bad part of the job
but if you're not naturally inclined to
do it it does take i think that little
push
for someone to remind you you should
also be doing this
part of the job great and speaking of
opinions on screenwriting have you
worked as a paid script reader
i've not worked as a paid script reader
for
a company i've
interned at two places where i was
a reader and i would provide coverage
but i do
private work for clients for
reading work and i give notes and calls
and
line edits as well oh is this something
that's new
that you've done yeah this is a new
endeavor for me i
had been giving notes to friends and
doing that for a long time
and a lot of them were really responsive
with
the quality of the notes that they felt
i was given and
a lot of them were encouraging me to
they say you should
do something you're actually really good
at giving notes and figuring out
not what you would do but what i should
do for my story
and figuring out where it might be
not holding together as well and
providing solutions
while still allowing me the freedom to
write my own story i just get a lot of
good response for the notes i was giving
and so with some encouragement i just
recently a few months ago started taking
on
private clients mostly which i find
through twitter
believe it or not okay and your website
has
the way to contact you if people want to
submit
their script yeah i have a whole page
that lists all my script services
and then i just have an email people
reach out to me for
the availability and rates and if we can
do it i'm
up to read anything we recently
published a video
that talked about 99 of screenplays are
rejected after the first scene
by most script readers so as someone who
is is now starting to read scripts and
and has done it in the past interning
what would you say to that
i'd say i think why most scripts get
rejected after the first scene is
really because by the first page you can
tell if someone is a good
writer or not and if it's not going to
carry you through then there's usually
not a strong enough reason to continue
reading
even if there's a great story underneath
it there's just too much else out there
that is a good story and has the writing
to back it up
so it's not that there's not something
great in there
it's just that that script is not at the
level yet that
it should be in order to move forward
into a film
so when you start reading um
a script what are some things that turn
you off immediately
not in terms of formatting and and you
know misspellings
but just how the story's structured
for me a big thing that will turn me off
pretty quickly is when i feel like the
characters
aren't truthful when they're not acting
honestly as human beings do
then i feel like i don't have a steady
footing for how this story is going to
play out because
i'm not actually watching a real human
being
go through their life
and so that'll probably be the first
thing that that turns me off
and it's going to be really tough for me
to stick with it as the story continues
so it's not necessarily a character who
doesn't know themselves
well and thinks maybe they're being
altruistic but then they have selfish
reasons or whatever it is
but it's really that the writer wrote
more of a stiff character like a
it's just sort of too one-dimensional i
think
that yeah one-dimensional characters
for me just don't feel real and i'm not
as interested
in reading a story that
has them how can you because like when i
watched your trailer
and the the character she looks
just like i believe that that's a real
person i saw
this person that i want to see her life
unfold even if it's tragic
she seems real to me if i were to be
reading something how would i see it
where
i felt that that person was real to me
versus
it was too fake
i think for me one of the keys to
real characters is specificity i think
that people
are incredibly idiosyncratic with
the way that they move through the world
everyone has their little tics and their
things
and their preferences and so the more of
those you can throw in to
a script uh onto a character is going to
make that character feel real
so whenever i see that in a script i
think that's real person because i don't
know
anyone like that and that's a specific
thing that a specific person would do
that's this specific person
and now i'm going to watch them through
the rest of the story
and if those specificities
fit into a larger theme
that the film or show is exploring
then even better okay so if you see
someone that
like i'm just taking an example of
someone i actually saw at a pizza parlor
and they didn't want their pizza
to be put into the oven until they saw
how it was cut
and he made a huge thing about it and i
guess they didn't listen to him and they
put it in
and he was mad and just i didn't want to
like totally stare at the guy but just
that is a very specific you can tell
that that's probably how he operates
yeah everything he does yeah and that's
that's a very specific thing
and you think it that sounds kind of
crazy
but you saw someone in the real world do
that
and you're telling me about it and you
were watching that and that was drama to
you so that was
real life specificity and i think that
we really respond to that so if you can
put that into your script
then people are going to respond to it
even though it's a fictional character
because we're still thinking well that's
a real person
even if we know it's not that's just
sort of the way that
we empathize with with characters so the
more
specific and unique your characters are
even if it's just in little small ways
is gonna make them feel honest and real
and truthful i think
did you have moments as a script reader
where you'd read one page
and be like i'm done this isn't holding
my interest
there were definitely times as a reader
that i would lose interest after
page one but my my job was to finish it
so i had to
and it's really tough to get through a
script when you're not interested in it
personally even if that's
my assignment that's my task and so
i used to kind of fight that and think
that oh well i'm a professional scripter
so i need to
look at this and figure out what's
working what's not working
and put my personal feelings about the
script aside
but once i started realizing that my
uh emotional reactions to what was going
on in the script is actually
a huge asset because that's the thing
that this script is trying to do it's
trying to
connect with an audience so once i
started listening to myself and
essentially using my
emotions as the tool for what was going
on i could think okay well i don't
really care about this character
and then try to reverse engineer why i
might not be caring about that character
and so that's where all the
craft and the study would come in but
that first thing that really helped me
in that job
was honestly just me david as a human
am i caring about this person do i hate
this person do i love it like do i want
them to get
together with that guy at the end or do
i want them to not
and if i don't want them to get together
but the script
i feel like is encouraging me to want
them to get together then there's
definitely a gap there
and that gap is where all the craft work
comes in but first i had to listen to
myself
how am i feeling about these people
about these characters
can you ever hate or dislike a character
and then
toward the end realize
actually you liked them you misjudged
them maybe it was too close to home
whatever it was
and then you realized actually they're
not that bad yeah absolutely and i think
that's some of the best
scripts i read when i feel like i've
been taken on a ride
and i haven't seen the ride being
built around me then that's probably one
of the best scripts i
would read and then on the flip side if
you ever read something where
the characters seem good and then toward
the end you realize
even though they haven't done maybe
horrible things that they're not
the best people or there's something
there's a character flaw that you
dislike
yeah i think there are definitely times
that i've read scripts
where i
liked the character off the bat and then
disliked them as it went on and
i think the difference between
that being intentional and that
not in that feeling not being
intentional
is where the craft of screenwriting
comes in
is it possible to have a horrible first
page and then
it turns out the rest of the script is
actually great i don't think i've ever
read a script that has
a horrible first page and the rest is
great i have read scripts where i think
the first page is horrible
and then later on i realized like oh
actually here's what was going on
i the wolves got pulled over my eyes
that was actually a great first page
that was intentional misdirection
that's definitely happened to me but
i've never read a script where that
first page was bad
i think it was bad and then the rest is
actually really great
as a viewer have you ever loved a film
or enjoyed it and wanted to go and look
at the script and then realize
wow the script really didn't live up to
how the movie ended up turning out which
was fantastic but somehow within the
production
and with the actors it just it just
transformed mm-hmm
there are definitely times i've seen
films that are great and i
want to go oh i gotta go check out that
script how how was that written
and then i go and the script doesn't
seem
as great as the movie turned out to be
conversely i've also seen films
that i thought were not really that
great but i had read the script and i
thought that's a fantastic script
so i think it's definitely a
collaborative process what we do
and understand that we don't have
control
we don't have full control over the
project and
that sometimes works to our benefit
because we can turn in something that
maybe
isn't quite delivering on the promise of
what we thought this project could be
but someone else can deliver that
promise and that's part of what i'm
banking on
as a screenwriter that someone else can
make my work even better
but also sometimes if i think i have
something great that doesn't necessarily
mean it's going to translate
and it's it's tough to say who
is ultimately responsible for
the finished product when there's so
many people that are collaborating
together
and i think that's one of the great
things about the job
but it i think can also be tough
sometimes when you feel like
i have this really great thing and then
you see it and you go okay well
that's what it is all right that's the
film i think there are
a number of reasons
a film can succeed and i think there are
a number of reasons a film
can not succeed both commercially and
artistically
and i think it's really difficult to
tell exactly
where things went wrong sometimes it is
but a lot of times it's sometimes
tougher even if you think it's this one
thing
that actually might be a symptom and the
cause might actually be elsewhere
interesting okay
okay so it seems like it's this but it's
not actually that
okay i think that uh
a film or tv show just has so many
moving parts
and other than the projects that
we're involved in directly we can't see
all of those moving parts we just see
the finished product and it's really
tough to diagnose
the machine as a whole just from the
thing that comes out of it
yeah you know i saw a film just this
weekend i don't want to say the name of
it because i loved it and i want to bash
it
but in the beginning it was too
fast-paced and the editing it was too it
was cut too fast and i'm like oh i don't
think i'm going to like this
and then bam something clicked it must
have slowed down something either i got
used to it
and i loved it and i didn't want it to
end but yeah i had that initial feeling
like oh i'm not sure this is going to
work for me
and then it did but i couldn't tell you
what it was it was just that process of
sitting there
seeing it and it just worked and i took
myself out of
being the theater goer and now i'm in
the story yeah it'll be interesting if
you were to re-watch it how you feel
about
those earlier things now now that you
know coming down the line you're going
to get really into it so it will be
interesting to see how that holds up on
a second viewing that's a good point
that's a good point yeah i'll have to
see it
what makes a great story i don't know if
i know what makes
a great story i
know i've watched or read a great story
when i'm
moved by it but i don't know if i'm
always great at
diagnosing even for myself why i
responded to that
films that i loved growing up or even
just recently saw
and loved i think it's like oh it's
because i love this about
the craft or the way they did this thing
or this thing but
the more i reflect on it the more
i see actually i'm just responding to
something
in there yes there's great craft but why
i think that's a great film
is probably more about me and what i'm
connecting with
in there and i i think that's always
important to remember
that what we do is
uh we're creating a bridge between us
and the audience and it creates the
the audience has to meet us somewhere on
that bridge and some people are going to
meet you pretty far
because they're connecting to that story
in
a deeper way based on their experiences
than others
and that doesn't necessarily mean that
your film or your script is bad
it just means that it didn't connect
with those people so you can make
a really good well-structured
well-crafted screenplay
and it is not going to connect with
everyone but it will connect with some
people
and you have to have that craft to back
it up but that story behind it
you don't have as much control over how
people respond to
i think i think you said
raiders of the lost architecture i love
raiders okay sorry okay
so is that sort of that adventure genre
is that
your thing so to speak or um
i think my thing would be
what i usually call grounded genre
so genre that has very real characters
within it i think
probably why i respond to raiders even
now
i mean i did as a kid and i loved it but
i think why i continue to love it is
because
uh indiana jones feels like a very real
person in this huge genre film
and even though he is doing kind of
insane genre
stunts and all that stuff he is
really grounded and i think that's part
of why i'm responding to it
as opposed to other genre films that are
a little bit more heightened in their
characters
and so i'm most interested in my work
in not a specific genre itself but more
taking those genres and
and really making sure that the
characters within
that film are grounded so a very real
person that might find themselves in a
heightened circumstance whether it's
sci-fi or fantasy or adventure but
is going to act the way that we might
react
in that situation and let's take another
harrison ford film the fugitive
would you say he was grounded in his
role i guess it's a totally different
role
he's still going on an adventure would
you say that's grounded as well
yeah absolutely i think that's part of
why han solo works so well
in the star wars films
is because he's a guy who is not
believing in
the force or any of this stuff he's just
a guy trying to
make a living it just happens to be
smuggling things on a spaceship
but he's not interested in any of those
necessarily big things at least
not at first in new hope or anything
like that but
he's a very grounded character and
harrison ford clearly has an aptitude
for
playing those types of roles little
sense of humor
sarcasm yeah yeah definitely believable
yeah
are you a planner and an organizer yes
i am definitely a planner and
organizer i think that's what i'm
probably most fulfilled doing is playing
and organizing
which i i guess makes sense because in a
sense that's what a screenplay
is just a an organized plan
for an emotional journey you know i'm
constructing
a essentially a train that the audience
is going to ride and i'm planning out
every little minute detail of that
ride and then trying to hide the
audience from
the rails and the car and i'm i'm using
empathy as a misdirection for
that so
i like knowing the destination
and then constructing the path
to it and then sort of hiding that path
for the audience
interesting and so do you always know
the ending
when you start writing a story
i always know the ending when i start
drafting when i first
am thinking about a story i don't
necessarily know the ending
and i'm scribbling a bunch of notes what
might be the ending what might be a
scene i'm
i do a lot of note taking and a sort of
loose free thought
of what whatever that i'm interested in
this project
i'm just trying to collect as much as
possible kind of out of my brain about
what's interesting me
about that thing and then i'll do
a treatment and i'll do that treatment
over and over
and over until it gets to a point where
i feel like that's the story i want to
write
and then i'll go to a draft so by the
time i'm going to a draft
i know the ending but i also know
everything leading up to
it and so my first drafts i can usually
write pretty quick but that's because i
just spent months
writing a treatment over and over and
over and it's different versions and i'm
tweaking different little things so that
everything as a whole is fitting
together
so in the draft i can i have a lot of
room to explore those nooks and crannies
particularly when it comes to those
character idiosyncrasies
and just little lines of dialogue
because i know that as a whole
this story will arrive at this natural
conclusion
or what should feel like a natural
conclusion obviously i've contrived it
but i feel good that i've set up the
pieces so that
it will necessarily arrive there and not
elsewhere
do you think planning and organizing is
one of your strengths
or are there times you wish you could be
less of a planner
there are times when i wish that i was a
little bit freer
in my writing i started taking
improv classes as a tool to
be less in my head and more
present and just open to possibilities
and it's been really helpful both
personally and then
also in my writing interesting okay
because you would think most writers
would have the opposite problem where
they were just you know
that they just wouldn't they weren't
able to get on task and so i i find that
interesting
i think that i try to
i try to plan the times in which i'm
freely thinking okay so this is people
plan then so i'm still planning but in
in my notebook i'm saying all right i'm
gonna
just freehand write this scene and i
don't know if it's gonna be in the movie
i don't even know who these characters
are sometimes it's just like character a
character b
but i'm just writing whatever because it
doesn't have to exist within
the film yet so there's a little bit of
a freedom there that allows me to just
explore different things
and then when i'm taking that notebook
which has a bunch of different things
i'm looking through
all right what after months of doing
this
what am i still responding to what am i
still interested in that scene
that actually i thought i was interested
in that but i'm not and so it's good
because i don't have to
i don't i'm not wasting time in the
draft of writing that scene when it has
to fit into a larger structure
of the screenplay i have that more
abstractly so i've planned that time
to do that and to like let myself free
associate
and just kind of see where characters
and lines of dialogue and set pieces and
everything is going
and then taking that into a treatment
i get to pick and choose and now i get
to organize all these thoughts that i've
collected
i just happened to stumble upon your
twitter i think you tweeted if you're
planning on writing a script in 2020 and
you haven't started yet
start today make a file do a title page
write your first slug line and then your
first line of action
tomorrow you can jump right in my
intention right in that tweet and i
guess i should say that
i wrote that on the 31st of december so
it's if you're planning on starting a
screenplay in 2020
start it in 2019 because
when you sit down and it's just it's
just this vacuum
of blankness there's just this sort of
feeling of like oh my gosh i have so
many possibilities
and i just don't know what to choose but
as soon as you get something down
regardless of what it is i think things
just really open up
because all of a sudden your
possibilities start to narrow
and there's a lot less time spent
in evaluating these possibilities as
opposed to these possibilities
so there's just an effective way to
continue moving forward
because you can always take those
possibilities you can take them later
and
translate them to other ones you we're
allowed to rewrite
so just get it going and don't worry
about facing the blank page and so that
was my advice of just
just write something down in 2019 and
it's going to set you up in 2020 for
success insofar as you will be writing a
screenplay
don't even worry about what it is yet if
that's what you're afraid of
do you think that's what stops a lot of
people because it seems like this
monumental
i'm writing a screenplay and now oh am i
going to take on this title as a
screenwriter
is it going to be a legitimate title
just just set it up
don't don't overthink it just do it is
it take some of the fear out of it
to do it this way yeah i think
sitting down and just typing
something or writing something longhand
just gets you moving
and i think that movement
is just a good habit to be in and i
would say that is more important
especially for beginning screenwriters
to
to learn that it doesn't have to be
great it doesn't have to be perfect it
doesn't have to be even what it will
eventually be it's not going to be what
it will eventually be
so don't worry about it being that
just get moving it's like training at
the gym
it's like if you want to lift 200 pounds
you first have to lift 100 pounds if you
want to lift 100 pounds you first have
to lift
50 pounds like just and not that i can
lift 200 pounds um but
i'm just saying you have to start
somewhere
and that where you start is not the
destination so just start and
you can go back and figure it out later
and also too is it is it less
intimidating when you think about wait a
minute i'm not actually going to be
writing like
full sentences sometimes for a script
yeah i think there's definitely a
freedom
in the way screenplays are written that
we are not beholden to
strict prose punctuation and grammar
and all that stuff you have
a fair amount of freedom there is a very
clear formatting for screenplays but
that formatting allows for i think a
tremendous amount of freedom
that once you are comfortable with i
think
really allows an authorial voice to come
through
was that something that was a surprise
to you that you didn't realize like
wait a minute i'm not writing an actual
novel here i don't have to
make sure that i'm completely
grammatically correct with something i
can just do sort of this cryptic
how's it going uh yeah you know i mean
just you know the in terms of
the conversation and and yeah i remember
the first screenplay i wrote
that was in perfect all the action lines
were perfect pros
and i had a table read of it and it was
it was horrible because it was the
slowest read of
my life and afterwards a friend who was
participating in the read came out for
me and she said your story is fantastic
i think this is great this
this could be a name maker for you
but you have to you have to change every
single action line
i was like well oh okay she's like yeah
just
it needs to be like a screenplay
and so i had this story but i didn't
have a good screenplay and
so i went back in and changed i didn't
make a single story
choice different but it's changed all
the action lines
and that was the screenplay that has
gotten me
more noticed than any of my other work
okay wow that was a nice friend
yeah was this table read here in l.a
yeah
okay great yeah i had a table read with
friends in la that just
put put together i have a small group
that
meets semi-regular whenever someone has
something they say who's available and
when are you available can we get
together for a read
and it's a combination of actors and
writers and so we'll give the actors the
bigger parts and kind of use the writers
to fill in some of the smaller parts
and hear it out loud and then
immediately
just sort of get feedback from everyone
are they doing the feedback after the
script is read through or
in the moment after it's read through so
we hear it once completely
i need to record it so i can hear it
back um i'll also record the feedback so
that i can hear that back
um which is also something i'd recommend
is just being used to recording
everything because if you have to pause
to take notes every time
you're not going to be present with the
person that you're talking to you'll
also
miss things and you'll go back later and
that note
you won't be able to make sense of but
you can hear it back and you hear
exactly how they said it now oh that's
right that's what they said
so definitely record everything
i bet that's really powerful to hear
your own work spoken by someone else
it's great you'll hear a line that you
go i think that line is going to kill
it's great and then it just
great reading but the line false flat so
the line is bad also you'll hear things
that you know a line that was just
functional like you needed that line to
get from a to b
and it's there and you think it's not
great but then someone reads it
and all of a sudden like that line pops
more than any of the others and you're
like
well i don't know if that line is
necessarily great but clearly there's
something that this actress found with
this character
that allows that line to pop and
figure out what that is because there
are going to be opportunities elsewhere
in the script
to use whatever that actor found in that
character to make sure that that is
in every other scene that that
character's in
you had a tweet recently about action
lines and it got a lot of traction
a lot of people engaged can we start
with
what action lines are aimed to
accomplish
i think that action lines are
aimed to accomplish two things tell you
what is happening but also how we
see what is happening
and
you can use words to
sort of secretly cue
your reader into how they should be
seeing what's happening
i think one of the coolest parts of
screenwriting
is that we can use words to cue in the
reader's brain how they see what's
happening
even without telling them how they
should see what's happening
let's see what kind of an example so if
we were to say
she entered the room with a sarcastic
grin
or she crept in
from this i don't know i'm i'm you help
me out yeah
i need some help here i think you can
if you want to start a line a toothy
grin
spreads across her face as the doorknob
clicks
and she enters the room the first thing
i'm gonna see
is that toothy grin so even though i
didn't say close up on mouth
the reader will probably just see
a mouth grinning because i haven't told
them yet that this is a room
so they're only thinking in terms of
what they've been
told because that's just the way our
brain works i'm not going to imagine
something that
no one has cued me to imagine but if i
wanted to say
the room sits vacant as a door opens
she enters smiling you're already in the
room
and you've i've told the reader that
there's a room which
a room is probably going to cue a wide
shot
and then the door opens and she enters
and she has the grin now it's the same
action in both
but i have used different words to
hopefully
cue the reader into how i think they
should be seeing it
and i haven't told the director
necessarily how to shoot it but i've
suggested what i think might be best for
the story
and then if a director takes that and
says that's great that
gives me an idea for something even
stronger and they
use a wide shot to get what i was trying
to achieve even better
because i'm not telling them how to do
their job i'm just suggesting it
but either way the director the actress
the production designer everyone knows
that all we need to do
is just get this actress entering the
room smiling i've just suggested what i
think is the best way
to visually tell that but even if none
of that gets across
she's still entering the room smiling
and
that's as far as i need to take it i
think
so the one where she's smiling or the
toothy grin which one do you think
is i like the toothy grin in some sense
because that keeps me like
hmm toothy as in showing the canines
is it like a little more mischievous or
is it she's overjoyed i think it would
depend on the context and
those are the kind of choices that you
get to make as a screenwriter
when you're deciding on about how to
tell
the audience how to
[Music]
see what is in your screenplay so if
it's really important
to me that is this is an establishing
shot of this character and i want the
first thing the audience
to see when they first meet this
character is her
figure in then i'm going to want to cue
that with
those words but if this is not
necessarily that important or there's
other
considerations or other reasons that
that's i don't want to draw too much
attention to this character
and her grin i might not do that and i
might just have her enter the room from
the wide because it's more important
that the room is vacant that's the
creative choice that i want to
have in the screenplay
perhaps this is an apartment that this
woman is entering where she lived
with her husband and she's had a good
day so she enters smiling but we already
know it's vacant and we see her face
drop
so it's more important that we see the
apartment vacant first but i could also
flip that we could be on her with the
toothy grin
maybe just a big smile but i can say big
smile
she opens the door and finds an empty
apartment her face falls
so i can basically even though it's the
same action i can swap those two
visually
with my words and actually create
different effects in the audience
in one of your tweets you mentioned
writing action lines
with special attention paid to word
order and what you call
anchoring nouns
what is an anchoring noun an
anchoring noun is a term that i
made up because i didn't know what else
to call it but for me it's the first
noun that you encounter that
communicates what sort of shot you
should be
seeing the action i'm describing
so if i say an orchard
sprawls across the valley i haven't said
wide shot
but orchard to me is the anchoring noun
that anchors you visually into a wide
shot
because you don't picture an orchard in
close-up because i've told you it's an
orchard it's a big thing
if i say an apple sits on a branch
then the anchoring noun would be apple
and i've kind of queued you into a
closer shot
even though i haven't said camera
close-up on or
anything like that so those nouns and
where you place them
are just what i call anchoring nouns
because it anchors you to the
image that i want you to picture in your
head
and does that also kind of correspond
with grounded stories grounded cinema
in some sense because it's sort of
i'm
maybe there's no correlation i'm not
sure if you could because okay it's all
right well because to me
this is like a like a it's just like a
little craft thing and depending on how
people use it
um yeah it's uh
it's a tool in the tool kit and i think
people can employ it to
any level of stories
it can be an incredibly heightened uh
not grounded like fun
space rom but you can still use anchor
nouns for
heightening some of that craziness
what is visual writing in a screenplay
to me visual writing is
writing with the notion that this is
something to be
seen so using
words that in my mind are visually
sticky
so a character walking across the room
doesn't evoke a very strong
visual thing for me but a character
leaping across the room
i guess that seems more visual to me
because it's just more of a
specific action so i can picture a leap
that's very specific
and it's different than a walk
okay yeah this walk sort of falls flat
but with leaping
there's more of an urgency to it whether
it's a positive thing or a negative
thing
okay like that i don't know if there's
more of an urgency to it but there's a
specificity to it
a character that shuffles across the
room
i can picture that and i can picture
that very differently than
a leap but a walk kind of falls flat
because we just see people walk every
day so there's nothing
inherently unique about that action
and if the character's just walking and
there's
they should not be doing anything else
then i think use walk it's not that you
have to
use something else but if there's
anything you can
give me that is just a little more
specific than walk
i'm gonna be able to picture it i think
a little bit easier
so if you don't want to call attention
to the walk if it's not
really a major thing in the story then
just maybe
keep it something like that walk
something more bland but if there's a
point to
what you're trying to make or this
character's going to be doing something
or setting it up for something
then that's where the more the more
visual the better
yeah and i think the more specific the
better
every noun and verb in your script
is an opportunity to tell the audience
something
and the more specific you can be with
your nouns and verbs
the less you have to use adjectives and
adverbs which saves you
space and so
a character reluctantly walks is more
words
than saying a character shuffles across
the room
or a character pads across the room
well i like where this is going this is
great yeah the more specific you can be
with your
nouns and your verbs the less adjectives
and adverbs you'll have to use in your
screenplay
do you see that a lot with nora writers
i think with newer writers the thing
that i
see the most is
more words rather than
less so overwritten
i think overwritten might be a way to
put it
how does someone prep for a spec script
i think there are as many ways to
prep for a spec script as there are
people writing
spec scripts because it's it's not an
assignment so you can do
kind of whatever you want to do
so i know some people
that just immediately dive in
because there's no pressure so they can
discover it on the page
i know some people that research for
months just to figure out
what they want to write about they have
a topic but they
don't know the story within it but they
know they want to write about this one
thing
so i think my advice to anyone
starting a spec script would be to don't
assume that your process
has to be what anyone else is figure out
what
you are going to benefit from the most
and just do that
have you ever heard of a screenwriter
writing a great script without an
outline yeah i've heard of screenwriters
writing great scripts without
an outline none specifically come to
mind but i know i've heard
those stories i i don't think i could
ever
do it um i'm still trying to write a
great script with an
outline so we'll see but
i think that everyone's
process is unique to them and i think
the best
writers have found a process
that is theirs and gets the best
results and i think that only comes
through engagement with yourself and how
you're working
and what your output is doing and what
you're getting out of
various steps of your process and
there is no one way to write a
screenplay
there is one way for you to write a
screenplay and i think
figuring out how to
do that is
just as valuable as writing the
screenplay if you want to have
a career
do you start every screenplay out with
an outline i
first start with a notebook once i've
decided okay this is a project that i
want to
write i buy a notebook for it i usually
try to sort of
theme the notebook so if it's like a old
like pirate adventure
i'll try to make it look i'll find a
notebook that looks like that um
and then i will just use that notebook
to just freehand
write anything i'm interested in in
regards to this
screenplay whether it's just like a very
vague idea of
i think this thing should happen or i'm
writing
a dialogue for a scene that might exist
in the screenplay i'm sort of
filling that notebook up and i don't
really have a timeline at that point so
i'm talking about spec scripts for me
i'm just
writing it writing it writing it until
hopefully a story will coalesce
and once i feel like that story's
coalesced
i'll try to write that story as
succinctly impossible essentially i'm
trying to write
the log line for it and if that log line
is engaging to me and i think
will move me if i think that story
that is told even in that little you
know one sentence
is moving enough to me i'll try to take
that sentence and i'll
turn it into a paragraph and if that
paragraph
is moving then i'll move on if it's not
i will continue to maybe reshape that
paragraph
and then that paragraph will become a
page that page will become
multiple pages into sort of a treatment
and then at the treatment
that's when i think i'm doing most of my
story work
i'm writing that over and over and i
will do that for
a couple of months maybe depending on
how often i can
work on it and once that treatment
is really resonating with me and is a
story
that again will move me then i can take
it and
start writing the draft and so it almost
feels like that draft is more like a
translation
project than writing something new
i'm taking something that exists in full
prose writing and then
put it into a screenplay format and so
all of the
little things that
exist in a screenplay that's when i'm
putting those things in because my story
i feel i already feel
incredibly comfortable about so i don't
have to discover any of the story things
i
just discover all those little things
all those little nooks and crannies
that happen when a story is now going to
be put on the screen and i'm translating
it there
and then i'll get that first draft and
then from that i'm moving into
rewrites and polishes and all those sort
of conversations
but i think it's helped me because i
feel like my
story usually doesn't go through too
many significant changes
once i'm on that draft once i'm in the
screenplay software
and writing it because all those changes
i've hit all those dead ends
all those things that i thought were
great that are not all those things that
i was excited about that didn't end up
doing anything for me i've already
figured that out
in that treatment process so i don't
outline so much as
try to just tell a story and tell it
fuller and fuller until that's a full
rich story
and then translate it to a screenplay if
that makes sense
it does so it almost sounds like this
little notebook that you buy that's
themed
it's like a scrapbook yeah okay so then
you're putting it's almost like a diet
part diary part scrapbook you're just
putting little notes
and it's like it's like filling up and
then by the time you get to the
screenplay formatting
it's already its own world in that
little
book yeah it already exists and i have
this full treatment that is pretty
detailed
and it tells a story so it's not an
outline because i don't so i don't have
to discover
how this character is going to convince
this other character of what they want
because i've done that in the
treatment but now i get to in the
screenplay figure out what are the exact
words that she's using to convince this
character
about what she wants or something like
that so a lot of the work
is um for me compared to how i think
some other people i've heard the process
some of that work is kind of split
where it's story stuff here and then
sort of screenplay stuff over here
when i'm in in the software and and
doing all the screenplay formatting and
stuff like that
are there any pictures in the little
notebook do you ever i mean
to help flesh it out or no stick figures
no i don't i actually don't use pictures
i think it's because i'm
a horrible artist and
um i don't do clippings or anything like
that
i think in every way i've ever been
creative it's always been
in words and ideas
and so anytime i've ever tried to
translate any
of my creative ideas through visual
stuff it just never works and so i've
just
i've just i think given up on that for
now maybe at some point i will
try to learn how to draw or something
like that but
it's probably why i do i'm a lot more
active on twitter than i am on instagram
because it's just where i feel the most
comfortable sure sure well instagram's
also very personal
and like hey this is what i had for
lunch and you know it was a great photo
of it and
yeah here's me you know with so and so
and some people that
you know it's just they're they're just
better sharing links to articles or
talking about writing or something yeah
yeah do you ever go back and look at
those notebooks
during the process or afterwards even
years later like oh wow this is this
notebook for this so this
notebook became this thing yeah i mean i
have them
on my shelf and i can see because
they're all different i can make oh
that's that project that's that one
and every now and then i might flip
through one and like oh yeah i had that
idea for that scene that never ended up
anywhere but there's something i love
about this
idea this this scene and it didn't have
a home in this project i thought it did
but maybe it'll go elsewhere or i'll see
something and
i think to myself why did i ever think
that was
interesting like who was i at that point
that wrote that little scrap of an idea
and why was i
interested in that so it's not just a
useful
tool creatively but personally it acts
as a little bit of
sort of uh like an idea diary of what i
was interested at the time
that i wrote that thing i think it's
cool too that you
have it in the theme of whatever the
project is
yeah and i definitely have notebooks
that are empty but i was like that's a
cool notebook but i can't use it yet
because i don't have an idea that fits
the feeling of that notebook um and
sometimes it
the notebook itself will get me going oh
i should write
a fantasy novel because that notebook
looks like a fantasy novel or something
like that yeah forget which author it
was that said
don't buy really pretty notebooks to put
like your feelings in
or creative right whatever because
you're going to be too precious because
it's so beautiful
if you buy something that it's not even
you don't care too much about it's like
the spiral notebook from the 99-cent
store
you're just going to be like cool i can
put whatever i want i can just
regurgitate it all here and i don't have
to be precious with it
i don't know that's just a thought but
there's so many beautiful notebooks that
you see at
bookstores if people go to bookstores
anymore but i remember back in the day
you know
and it would almost be too intimidating
writing something that's
leather bound and i feel that way i i
keep
a personal journal and
it's a lovely leather-bound journal was
a gift from my sister
years ago and um
i am a little bit intimidated to write
because
the notebooks for my screenplays i'm
just collecting scraps of ideas and i
feel like i'm just kind of spilling my
brain out onto it but my personal
journal i feel like what if someone
finds this and
reads it i want it to be
thoughtful and interesting and i want i
want to appear
smart even though it's for me i'm still
thinking some
how about how this might be seen by
others
and it's because this notebook feels
like it's something that would be read
by others whereas those other notebooks
from my screenplays it's like if that is
read by others that's great because it's
it's not supposed to be a thing it's not
supposed to be readable
but um if this diary
would be something
that would be read i would be terrified
and even though it's not
i'm still terrified and i think it's
because it's a really nice journal
sure sure and it's not you you want to
write in the king's english
yeah pen or something you know the other
one
you put whatever profanity just whatever
thoughts yes
not that you would be doing that my
handwriting is also
terrible and so i also think about i
need to write legibly
in this notebook because what if
someone discovers it years from now and
reads it i want them to
not think i couldn't write good
handwriting
sure that's interesting yeah
what moves you when you're writing i
think what moves me
is seeing real
people
go through something
and
i don't know i have to really sort of
think think about it that's
a very that's not a good answer
well that's why i think a lot of us go
to the movies and and
choose certain types of movies some
people just want
to be entertained and they want a happy
ending a neat little package
and others they want to see people go
through something yeah i'm trying to but
i'm
i'm trying to think of what i want to
see people go through and that's what i
think that's why i think it's not good
it's not that it's a badass but i don't
think it's as
accurate as it could be because i think
that
things that move me are real people
in extraordinary situations
going through something that is
incredibly
human and i think that might be why
i love shakespeare so much particularly
the histories
because i will never be king of england
but when i see the king of england talk
about what it's like
to be up at night and i know what it's
like to be up at night
and dealing with something
then i'm now connected in a way to what
it might be like to be the king of
england it's just the thing that keeps
me up at night is way different than
it keeps him up at night but the fact
that we are both
have this same experience tells me that
that's another human that is
going through something that i go
through and we're connected through
empathy and
i find it very moving when i
see people in these situations that i
will never find myself in
but if i was in that situation i might
react
the same way because that reaction is a
very human reaction
that's what moves me
right this is off on a tangent a bit but
just
in watching master class they had one on
political leadership
it's not necessarily a class i would
gravitate toward but it was just really
interesting and i loved the framing of
it and the way it looked
and they just talked about how a lot of
the great presidents
forced themselves abe lincoln forced
himself to go to the theater
different people to get out of that
mindset because they were so focused on
what to do with this war or that war
and they were criticized for it but they
needed that
time away from it because it did keep
them up at night
so that just reminded me of that where
they had to get away
from the problem of war and these
different things for a short time so
that they could come back and try to
solve
or deal with it yeah they needed that
escapism yeah
well i think that uh art
and art that is storytelling
forces us to engage with ideas
of ourselves in situations that we might
not
ever find ourselves in but when we're
forced to think about that
it opens up our minds in ways that we
can't get because we don't we just don't
get that experience in the real world
so i think that we part of the reason we
go to the theater we go to the movies
and we watch tv
is even if it's subconscious it's so
that we can experience these lives that
we would never
experience but because that's a human
life and we're
humans in a way we get to
expand our minds in ways
that we need to
do you have a writing routine that you
follow i have two answers for
if i have a writing routine that i
follow and
one is yes i have a writing routine
two is i don't always follow that
writing routine
the best work i've ever done was when i
followed that routine
but for some reason i i don't follow it
all the time and
it's tough and sometimes it's because of
just what else i have going on in my
life that routine that i really
liked and worked for me didn't
it's just no longer sort of an option
for for what i have going on right now
and other times it's just tough to
just sit down at the desk and write even
though i know i already have a plan
to do that it's just
tough you know you don't want to and
so sometimes i don't i fail at sitting
down and writing
but when i was following it
it was great and when i do follow it
it's great because
it forces me to write and the routine
was basically
i would get up and two hours in the
morning
i would write and then that was
it for the day as far as official
writing time i would still
pull out a notebook or if i was really
inspired i might open the computer and
and write some more but those two hours
i would set the timer
and i would write at the end of that two
hours i would stop no matter where i was
no matter whether i
felt like i could keep going for another
two or i was like thank god i just i
barely made those
two hours that felt like a slog
but having it be time-based told me that
it doesn't matter
what i've written as long as i've shown
up
and i have written and so some days
those
two hours would produce you know 10
pages other days it would produce
one but i was measuring whether or not i
was doing my job
by the time i was spending doing it and
not necessarily the page
count or the word count because i think
that so much of what we do is up here
and it doesn't always translate to
the pages and so that one page that i
wrote over that two hours that might
have been really
difficult and was a lot of thinking and
feeling and kind of moving through what
was going on there
and that one page is great output for
those two hours
and those other 10 pages i wrote the day
before might not be
great so i shouldn't measure my
progress with what was going on the page
but more about the fact that i could sit
down show up
and do the job does active
or passive voice come into play with
screenwriting
or is it just that's more with prose
i think active and passive voice doesn't
come up
in screenwriting for me i don't know
if that's because i'm just not thinking
about that
as much um so i'm not sure
okay yeah just because sometimes you
know they say well
don't write in passive voice and i just
wasn't sure with the rules of
screenwriting is it a faux pas
to to write in passive voice for
you know a screenplay even if it's just
little like action line but it's not
i think that one of the things that's
great about
screenwriting is that there are no
[Music]
hard rules so if there's a reason that
the passive voice should be used here
for an effect it's permissible like you
can
do whatever you want and so i think
understanding why this action line is
better in a passive voice as opposed to
an active voice
or vice versa is more important than
adhering to any sort of you should never
write in the passive voice you should
never do this because
for every rule that was laid out there's
a bunch of
examples of it being broken and broken
successfully and i think you can break
it successfully because
you know why breaking it is going to
produce a
greater effect than adhering to it
and one of the freedoms of the
screenplay format is that
you have so much room to break all these
rules
if someone comes to you and finds out
your screenwriter and you know the
industry
and says you know what i do this other
job in my life but i have this
screenplay that i wrote
i know it's amazing how do i get it to
the right person to get this made
i know this thing is amazing there's no
doubt about it so just
do you know any names that i can just
get this screenplay too
so i can have it made is is the question
do i haven't known any names because the
answer would be no
uh well okay there you go so that that
takes off that box
this exact thing this happened to me at
my sister's wedding
oh okay that's weird because i was
thinking about it last night what if
someone came to you
my sister's wedding last year it was
near the end of the reception
and i had given a speech i was the man
of honor
and it was a i think a decent speech so
a lot of people
like oh do you are you a comedian are
you i just oh i write screenplays so i
write a little bit and um like oh okay
and i think maybe
other people had mentioned that so later
this guy who i had never met before in
my life
comes up to me and he says i have a
great screenplay i think
it's really it's perfect for for you
know
this audience and here so you know what
can we
do with it how funny i was literally
thinking like what what would happen if
someone did that to you yeah and you're
sort of taken aback because
um it's funny because it's never
happened to me
here in l.a where you think people would
be talking about that more
and so i'm not even in that kind of mode
and
near the very end of the reception it's
been you know a big
full long day and
everyone's tired but still loose from
all their drinks and everything and
this guy who i never met he's not part
of my extended family or anyone i
i could not figure out how he was there
at the wedding
because he approached me alone and he
says i have this i have this screenplay
he didn't have it but um he says i have
a screenplay
and it's i think it's fantastic and i
think it's great and
i what can i do with it i said well you
should talk to
anyone you know in the
the film industry that you know well
that might be able
to do a favor for you but
i think the thing to
remember in those types of situations
if you're the one approaching someone is
that it is
a favor so you should ask
people that would be willing to stick
their neck out for you because they know
you
this man was a stranger to me and
reading a screenplay is a fair amount of
work even just from a time perspective
so even asking for that is a
favor from a friend and
i i didn't know that guy and so that
wasn't something i felt comfortable
doing because
if i just accepted screenplays from
every stranger that approached me i
would spend my life reading the
screenplays of
strangers and so
yeah i would i would just say maybe make
sure that you know who you're
approaching if you're going to
say i have a screenplay for you that's
really interesting because
it was late at night and i i posed this
question to david
and i said i wanted to ask you that
imagine someone came up to you i
envisioned it more at a restaurant
and just said like oh hey i do this for
a living i'm an accountant whatever
yeah but i have a screenplay that i've
written and i know it's fantastic i know
it's going to be
awesome what's the next step to get this
thing made and so that was
i asked david his opinion and he gave me
this very long
interesting answer i would never have
thought of that answer
but i think it's a touchy thing because
pete and
the last thing yet it was with it's
probably not ready to be made yet
yeah and i think um
uh depending on whether you use that
answer or not
or you're able to use parts of it
because he because the guy who
approached me was
pretty aggressive it sounded like a bad
idea and i was uncomfortable in
situations so i mean that's all all the
context i think if someone came up to me
and they were sincere and respectful and
was not doing it on the the day of my
sister's wedding
i i would probably give a different
answer so let me think about what i
would
uh that was kind of a a bad version of
someone approaching but if someone does
that and they're they're genuine and
if their question is what is my next
step that i would
i'd happily answer um it's when
someone it's it's it's the fact that i
was approached
and they said what you know can you do
something
what can you do yeah and i think that's
that's the big
thing that that really changes that
conversation
someone's asking for advice and they're
can ask respectfully and they say i
don't do this for a living
i am you said an accountant or something
else but i have a really great
screenplay
idea i would probably
ask who else thinks it's a great idea
and if they don't have
any answer to that other than themselves
i would say then
you're not sure yet and you should give
it to people to read
if if other people are saying it's great
even if they're
at first friends and family then go to
the next step and give it to other
people look
online for you know
message boards and on twitter people are
always trading scripts back and forth
trade it with someone who has no
stock in their personal relationship
with you and is willing to tell you if
it's great or not and you can tell them
hey i don't need any notes i just want
to know if this
is good and they can give you a
one note reply of yes i think it's good
or no i think it needs some work
and if you continually get people saying
yes i think this is good
eventually
it will find the hands of someone who
can get it into the hands of someone
who wants to do something with it
but i'd say for just recognize that
everyone else
working in los angeles and trying to
work in los angeles and elsewhere in
within the industry
also has a screenplay that they think is
good and they have written
at least five times as many as
you now you might have a unique
perspective because you're not
if you are an accountant for a huge
firm and you have some really
interesting stories from that firm you
might have a good screenplay about that
um does that necessarily mean the
screenplay you have written is a good
screenplay about that
i'm not sure but you have a perspective
but you just might not have a
screenwriting craft
so you might want to partner up with
someone who does
that you trust and it might take some
time to build those relationships and to
find those people
but screenwriting is not
a hobby that
usually turns into just a success it
might happen but i think it's very rare
so if you have a screenplay that you
think is good
there's a shot that it might go
somewhere but
it might just exist as a really good
screenplay for
you i think it's interesting too what
you said
it's not so much don't approach somebody
and say what can you do for me
do it from the what can i do to get it
out there and not
put the onus on you
yeah i think
asking for advice i'm always happy to
to talk about and i think
whenever someone asks me for advice i
always end up asking a lot of questions
because there is no
one way to do anything
in hollywood so it's always about kind
of well how are you
where are you right now and what is the
best possible avenue to
achieve what you want to achieve so i'll
always end up just asking a lot of
questions
before figuring out what i would
recommend
and that i'll end up talking forever
because everyone loves to give advice
it's very flattering to be asked for
advice it's not very flattering to be
asked to do something for someone
and so
figuring out that which one of those
conversations
it's going to be i think is
on my end crucial to figuring out how
much i want to really engage with this
person or maybe shut it down
before the ask is coming down the line
i have a
sort of uh self policy
of never asking anyone to
read my work in like social settings i
have
friends that we have understandings with
hey when you have something can you send
it to me for notes and
if you have something i'll give you
notes but that understanding already
exists before i'm going to
send it to them but if i'm meeting with
someone for coffee to talk about my
script
and they haven't offered to read it i
will just not
ask them to read it now maybe there are
places and times that i could have done
that it would have been fine
but more often than not i get asked
can i read your script so i found that i
don't actually
need to ask i can just
have a genuine conversation with someone
and if they're interested they will ask
and if they're not interested
then i would have been wasting my time
and theirs to ask them to read it anyway
if they
if i tell them kind of what my story is
about and they want to read it
they're going to ask for it you don't
have to go around offering your
screenplay
if you have a good idea and you say hey
i have an idea for a screenplay
it's kind of about this and i'm
interested in it i probably will ask for
it
if they're interested and they have the
bandwidth
to read it they will probably ask for it
if you ask them to read it already puts
them a little bit
on their heels because now it feels like
an assignment and
well i wasn't necessarily interested in
it so i don't know
now i have to gauge like is it worth
in this conversation having this little
attention where i have to now say
no i don't want to read it right now or
i don't know come back to me when you
think it's ready
um you can usually get a sense from
someone of
how they're talking about it and
where they might be both in their career
as a screenwriter or
in their their project itself kind of
where they are in the process and if
it's something that you want to do
and if it is at a point where i'm
interested in reading it i would
i would ask for it and i think that in
most of my experiences people have
treated me the same i rarely have to
offer my work explicitly for someone to
ask for it and if someone doesn't ask
for it it
probably wouldn't have been in their
wheelhouse anyway
yeah and maybe it's also too like an
industry protocol
like the unspoken sort of thing where
maybe when people are new
to la or just to the world screenwriting
in general it's just
pitching whoever but i've seen people at
industry events just be
just brutally aggressive and it's a turn
off i've watched them with other people
with
producers and different things and well
how do i get in contact with you oh
look i'm on the internet you can just
look me up you know and they're just
like hounding this person and i'm
thinking
i don't think this is working for them
but i could be wrong but
i think there's a there's just a way to
do it and i think
it takes time to know that that's really
not the avenue
yeah i think there's some people who
have figured that out they're
they're charming they're able to get in
there and get people to read
their work i am not one of those
people and so i just
once i stopped trying to figure out how
to
get people to read my work and just be a
little bit more
open and conversational about my work i
ended up getting a lot more read
requests from that
because i think people felt like i'm not
trying to sell them on anything
i'm just talking and
of the people that have read my work
since then those
relationships and conversations have all
been better because it's all people who
have reached out to
for to me to read my work so they're not
it wasn't something that was forced upon
them so it's naturally i'm gonna have a
better
success rate if that's what you want to
call it of people that
are resonating with what i'm doing
yeah and i think if people feel safe
with boundaries and they they see that
you're not gonna just
totally hound them about something i
think they're more apt to be open too
yeah and i will say i've been that other
person that
is not getting red and i feel like i
have to get something in someone's hands
and
i mean it's it it comes
it feels desperate because it is a
little bit desperate i've been
in those desperate situations where i
feel like i have not had any
screenwriting traction
for months and
i totally sympathize with everyone
that's in that situation and
you ever everyone will i i've done it i
will probably do it again
everyone's been there it's not it's
something that we can i think
work on but i think it's human to
be desperate for validation but also
for getting things going for your career
right but if someone's in the restroom
and you're like waiting outside trying
to pitch them i think maybe that's
i mean i'm not saying you're doing that
but i've heard of other people where
that's happened
yeah i probably wouldn't wait outside a
restroom i would not in any situation
i would not advise that or they're at a
dinner with family and
and i've seen that as well and someone
approaches them and
you know forgive me i just need a moment
of your time and i think that's
that's that's a real touchy thing to to
do that you know
yeah and i think one of the things to do
to avoid situations like that is to try
and attend as many industry
events as possible because people are
going to be a lot more open
in those situations because someone that
is there is there to
engage with that part of their life
someone who is at dinner with family
is not in a professional setting and
they're not there to talk about
your work they're there to be with their
family so if you want to be in the
situations where you can approach people
and talk about what you're working on
and meet people then you need to be
attending those events
and not chasing people down in other
areas of their lives
right because it could actually be a
fantastic script and now you've lost
that opportunity
right because the approach was wrong so
yeah right and i think
also putting the relationship over your
specific project is also something
that's really
important because you might have
a great script and you make a really
bad first impression and they're not
going to work want to work with you on
that great script
but if you make a good first impression
and your script isn't that great but
they
really like you and they say this one
might not be for me
but keep in touch it was really fun
talking with you
then there might be something down the
line
when you do have a great script or you
have a great script and it's just not
something that they're interested in
right now but you make that bad first
impression and you burn
that bridge so a relationship is
something that can
pay dividends over time and
also is just more honest and treats
people as
ends and not means so always
prioritize that over i need you to read
this right now i need
i gotta get this made it's so good
what's the most amount of time you've
put into a screenplay
and was it worth it the most amount of
time i put into a screenplay
it's tough because i haven't measured
exactly how much
time i've worked on it but i know that
the longest
from idea to a
finished draft was
five years and that's just to the end of
the screenplay that screenplay is still
sitting there not you know no film has
been made out so that's just
five years to what is for me a finished
draft
um sort of working on it sporadically
sometimes
every day other times it kind of sat
dormant for a few months and i worked on
other projects or whatever
but that's the longest of anything i've
done
five years why did it take so long
maybe that's not a long time no um i
think it took
a while and it was written in sort of
fits and starts because it was one of
the first
projects i started once i
started seriously writing so i didn't
know
yet not necessarily not that i didn't
know what i was doing because at times i
still don't feel like i know what i'm
doing when i'm writing a screenplay but
i didn't know
a process that worked for me in terms of
creating something
so i just started writing i had a loose
outline and i just started writing
and i just kept hitting dead end after a
dead end
or i would figure something out that
didn't feel like a dead end but i just
it wasn't interesting to me so it just
wasn't nothing was happening
and so i essentially had to
start that project almost like i'd
continue to start it over and over
because i didn't have a process yet that
i felt comfortable with
and i didn't really know
what i was interested in writing about i
had a story idea but i didn't know why
that was a story idea that interested me
and moving forward it was always
important to me that when i was writing
something
i always understood before i really got
into it
why i am interested in that story
and why i'm going to take that across
the finish line and that's been a really
useful tool
to help me with other story ideas that
i've had
that i think would be great movies i
think they're so cool
but i'm maybe not the one to write that
so
i shouldn't go after that yet but
there's still something that might
interest me so
i'll keep it in there and at some point
i go oh
i'm that's what i'm interested in that's
the theme
that comes out of that story that
resonates with me
and now i'm ready to start digging into
that it sounds like that story has a lot
of meaning for you
the initial idea um
it now it does it didn't at first
because i didn't have anything but once
i discovered that then i was able to
finish it and take it across the finish
line and understand
what i was interested in writing
about okay do you think you'll
have it made at some point or is it
something where it's almost you know
certain stories people are like
like you said this isn't the story for
me to make but
it's a great idea um i think at this
point it's
a story that i'd love to see made but in
terms of where i am in my career right
now
it's a very big project
this was at a time when i was writing
before considerations
of my career what is the best
story that i can write and get into
the hands of producers i know and have
relationships with so this
project just isn't a good fit for the
people i know right now
and so it's still just kind of sitting
dormant and it's been out to a few
people to read for
feedback and thoughts um but nothing has
really
happened with it yet
what's the fastest you've ever written a
full screenplay the fastest i've ever
written
a full screenplay was
about three and a half weeks
and that was writing
about four hours a day
and on the road trip that i went on
figuring out where
i was going to move when i knew that i
was going to leave atlanta and pursue
screenwriting
i was lucky enough that a friend offered
his
family's cabin just outside of reno he
said no one is no one's there right now
if you want to stop by and visit you can
use it as a as a
sort of a waypoint nice and my
girlfriend and i ended up
stopping by and we had just been so
exhausted from the trip and so we ended
up staying there for about
three weeks with his permission we said
hey we think we want to like
kind of sit for a while i want to focus
on a screenplay idea that i have
and can we just kind of take this as
almost almost a month of a retreat and
that is
the only thing i did for those three and
a half weeks that's the only thing i
thought of i was
writing i would get up i would
write for two hours have lunch write for
the two hours have dinner or
something in that order but uh no
casinos no no casinos
no i would get up i would write have
lunch i would write i would read a
screenplay
have dinner and then i would watch a
movie and both the screenplays that i
was reading
in the evening and the movie i had
picked as
something that was i wanted to either
examine
um craft wise or thematically was
similar enough to the story i was
writing so i was just in that mode
all day non-stop and i just wrote that
screenplay
and in about three and a half weeks and
i haven't changed too much
of it since i did a little bit of
rewriting but most of that came out of
that
extremely focused work and i don't know
a time in my life that i've had
that sort of freedom to just create
something that is just purely for me
with no
considerations for for job whatever it
was just that was all i was doing i was
essentially paying myself
to do that um and it was great it was
really fantastic
what time of year was that in reno um
was it winter or no
this was in september
okay so the the weather was nice um
i was i was doing that six days a week
and then one day
was uh we would do a day trip we'd go
we went and we hiked in tahoe we like
um hiked some stuff around reno
so it was six days of
focused uh work and then
one day to take advantage of where we
were did the film get made
nope okay still do you think you'll ever
have it made um or it was an experiment
it was an experiment i wanted to try
and i wanted to write something
contained
and i thought maybe if i wrote something
it could also be a stage play
and so right now the film kind of exists
in this uncanny valley between
stage and screen and is neither a
good it's not really a good fit for
either so
i think if i wanted to seriously pursue
it
i would have to really examine is this
something i want to see
on screen or do i want to make it a
stage play
and
make some craft decisions uh from that
perspective
sounds like though it was a good lesson
and discipline not that
it sounds like you are very disciplined
anyway but to really like
and you're in a strange place where you
want to explore there's lots to do in
reno
yeah um so if it's good so it's not so
good yeah
um you know what i'm saying and so it
was a lesson in discipline like can i do
this
yeah and that was the first time that i
that was the first time that i wrote
something on spec
in a serious way i'd kind of written my
own stuff before but i'm
not in any real
capacity even if even if that's just for
my own
sort of mental state this is the first
time i said i'm going to try and write
something at the end of this
i'm going to try to give it to people to
show that i
can screenwrite um and
everyone that i've shown it to and we
said great characters great story
but i don't quite know where this
belongs
uh but good writing and so
i moved on to other projects since but
uh we were talking about validation
earlier and that was another
time when i got some validation on
a project of mine even though it wasn't
great
it was good enough that people were
seem to be surprised by how oh you're
you can write you're actually pretty
good
we always hear that sort of the romantic
notion of oh i'm gonna
you know go away and write the great
american novel or whatever it is
screenplay
and then too many things distract you
and get in the way and so i think
just as a mere test of can you keep that
commitment to yourself
that's excellent that's pretty cool yeah
when there's
when there's nothing else going on yeah
it's it's like the greatest thing in the
world to just sit down and just continue
to
write your story but uh
you know that for me uh
where i am right now that's not a
sustainable lifestyle
and that's completely focusing
on the craft of screenwriting
and i was completely ignoring of course
all the
the career side of screenwriting of
calls and emails and relationships and
everything
so even that as much as i might want to
do that
even if i had the money to do it i don't
think i'd be able to sustain a career
doing that because
you have to do all the other things that
it requires to
make a career in screenwriting and a lot
of that is relationships
your latest screenwriting credit is long
gone by
and you you share credit with co
co-writing on that
yes with uh andrew morgan yeah he was
the director
okay great you tell us what the story is
about sure
it's about a a mother an
immigrant mother living in middle
america and
on the same day she finds out that
her visa she's on a six-month visa that
that
continually gets renewed
and she finds out it's not going to be
renewed
and on the same day she finds out that
her daughter was accepted into
college but it's a it's a state school
but because she's technically not
a state resident she has to pay out of
state tuition and she just can't afford
it so she finds out all this information
on the same day
and basically has to figure out what is
she
going to do she sees the life that she
wants for her daughter and why she came
to america for it
and she sees that if she can't get her
into this school that it
might not happen and so after exhausting
all of her options she
decides that she's gonna rob a few banks
okay that's and when i and i
heard this story from andrew that's
where i really leaned in i was like oh
she's gonna rob somebody okay that's
when i really got um
interested and we were just talking
over coffee about it we had some mutual
friends that put us together and so we
just
decided to meet up and we'd kind of
actually
the meeting had been like scheduled and
then rescheduled for like
eight months that we were planning to
just meet up and meet each other because
we had some mutual friends from from our
time in atlanta
and there was no sense of this is going
to be a job or anything like that
but i met up with andrew and he's just
telling me and he was sort of figuring
out
he was debating where to what piece of
information to lead with does she find
out that she's going to get deported
and that's the first piece of
information or does she find out that
her daughter got into school a really
nice
college but can't afford it and figure
out there and we're just talking about
so i sort of gave my
two cents and then a few days later he
goes i really liked the way you were
thinking about my story
would you be interested in doing a
rewrite
and i said yeah that sounds cool
and sorry was this based on a
documentary that he
and the the actress producer had done
the documentary it was not based on
a specific documentary at least not to
my knowledge he
he was very involved in some of the
immigration issues and stuff
going on at the time and he had also
heard of a story about
a group of women in florida that were
robbing banks without guns they were
just walking up
quietly and just taking money from the
tellers
in a very quiet way and he thought there
was something fascinating about that so
that's sort of how the
the bank robberies are very low key in
the film
and he had kind of taken some of these
ideas
uh and teamed up with an actress that he
knew well
and he knew could pull off this this
character because it's a lot of
it's a lot of her and a lot of her in
silence with herself which is
really tough for a
for a film to watch uh for the the
length of time that
he was thinking we'd be on her without
cuts and i was a little hesitant at
first but after seeing on the screen i
know
he was right she's magnetic and everyone
just you could watch her
um seemingly do nothing and you see
everything
going on and that's the character and
that's what they knew and so i came in
essentially as more of like a carpenter
to help just build a few things that
they were
needed some work on and well we put the
film together
and he shot it in
[Music]
just a few weeks and i think it turned
out great in
where did you shoot it it was shot in
indiana
you found a small town that looked very
much
like the town that we were envisioning
this happening in
and he basically just leveraged the
town as his production
design and so everything you see in the
film
is was just discovered in the town very
little
had to be made
and there was a lot of value in making
it
real and a place that people live
and it looks like a place that this
story would take place
and how did he know that town um
i'm not sure actually okay yeah yeah
because the trailer looks beautiful and
you can see
it does seem very not rust belt but you
know you just you i
envision a small town and you'd set off
camera that was one where maybe
a factory had closed or people were it
just yeah the
the town um the town in the film is
uh supposed to look just sort of
in its i'd say economic decline
and so i don't think the town he shot in
necessarily looks
exactly like the way it does in the film
but he did a good job of if it
if it was a location that looked like it
might be next economic decline
that's the one he shot and then the
really great great one right over there
just keep that off camera
and so he did a really good job at
shooting what felt like a
real town that
was uh a factory might have closed in
and so he had already written the script
sorry yeah
yeah he had written i think three drafts
of the script i i think
i i think was the fourth fourth draft um
and i'm not quite sure because he really
gave me a lot of freedom
to move things around in a very big way
and that was really one of the
things that i think allowed us to
actually finish
when we did because he was already in
pre-production and there was the
shooting date already
scheduled we're gonna start and there
were times when
i was writing and he was in indiana
location scouting
and i'd be writing the scene and i would
get notifications we had a shared
dropbox with the
location photos and i'd be seeing the
locations fly in on my
monitor of the thing i was actually
writing
so it was a very quick turnaround
but at the same time there was a lot of
sort of freedom and
mobility there because i didn't have to
think about a lot of these things
because it's like
you know interior laundromat i don't
have to think about what this looks like
because there's the photos like i
already know
and i already knew a lot of the pieces
and i had
the ability to move them around within
the script i just couldn't
add uh too much or take away too much
because cash
actors had been cast and certain
location deals had already gone through
and it just
it was going to be too much work to
pull those out find new ones and so
it's so it's like someone um
giving you an erector set
and no instructions on how to make it
but you can't
these are the pieces you have and i kind
of want it to look like this
and so andrew knew his story very well
and so we were really able to move
quickly in terms of making the
screenplay
something that supported that story
because he knew it in and out
and i was able to take the screenplay
and i'd send pages every night and he'd
get back to me every morning
of yes that's great oh no this this
isn't quite gonna work because here's
why
and he was very quick with his notes and
very
succinct and spot on and how long did
the whole rewrite process take because
you said that was his third draft when
he said it to you
yeah about five weeks
yeah we did about a week and a half
on a very rough outline making sure that
the big pieces were
were there where we wanted and he was
comfortable with me moving forward on an
outline
and then once that got the
thumbs up then i had about three and a
half weeks to
do the draft and of course it's all
digital but it very much
felt like that last day of like
passing but it's like running and just
like here's the screenplay and someone
grabs it and just like goes out and like
they were shooting it like two days
later and
it was wild i i um i had some other
stuff going on while they were shooting
so i was
uh every now and then getting like an
update from
the set or a question or two but for the
most part they took it and ran with it
and um i trusted andrew with the story
he had been
in that world much longer than i had so
i
felt like cool they're taking care of it
and then
a couple months later he showed me a
rough cut
when he showed me the rough cut it was
it had come together
far quicker than i thought it would and
it looked fantastic
i only had two
thoughts on it i only had two notes
there was one
thing at the beginning and i said i
think this cut is just
a frame or two too early because you can
you can hear her
breath but we're not seeing her it was
something like that um
and then at the very end there was a
shot of the
american flag and if you see if you see
the film i think
it deals with um immigration issues
and even though
the main characters
um are from another country i i feel
like
the film and i told this to andrew is
inherently american he's made a very
american film
um in my perspective
and i said i think the shot of the flag
near the end
i don't think you need it i think we
already feel this
and it feels just like one one thing too
far
and he goes i was thinking that yeah
yeah i and so that was we we
both notes we'd we'd like agreed on and
he was already kind of thinking about
and i said but that's just my two cents
and if you want you know obviously
you have a vision for it i think it's
it's great he goes well no i think i
think you're right we'll
take those two things and it's pretty
close to what the
final cut is well even in the trailer
she says i can't go back
i haven't seen the film yeah i'd love to
but the trailer
is excellent and she says i can't go
back and you feel it in that moment that
there's probably many reasons but you
can tell
this is her home now she feels you know
so i don't know if the american flag was
i didn't see that part but did you feel
that it was too obvious
or yeah it was just because it was just
part of a
the shot was part of a montage
and it was just some footage that he had
picked up
throughout the town they were constantly
just shooting b-roll
and it gives the town a real lived-in
feel and so it was not
in the script and i just thought within
this montage
all these images are specific
and feel like kind of
um that classic kind of nostalgic
feeling of america
so just to like put a shot on the flag
you just didn't need it because we were
already having
these images that were evoking america
without saying
hey did you get it by the way here's the
american flag um
and so we
we just didn't need it talking about
scripts being overwritten
it is a similar thing it's like you're
already communicating the idea
that you want to communicate you it's
not that this is changing anything it's
just you don't need it
and if you can ever simplify always
simplify
because the audience is at that point
they're just going yeah i get it move on
let's you know give me the next piece of
information
well very cool and the film screened in
la
it's screened the film premiered in new
york at hbo's
new york latino film festival and then
did a few other festivals i was in
england at the time of the new york
premiere so i could i couldn't attend so
the first time i
saw it in in a theater with an audience
was
at the that film festival was the it was
so small but
um so much like the little
after party thing i like i've never seen
so much kind of money spent on little
things like
there was a um remote control
cadillac escalade that was delivering
beers
oh my goodness throughout the party and
the most
bespoke uh like gelato company
presenting these things it was it was it
was crazy i
i was i felt totally out of my element
what's the most joy you've had as a
writer the most joy i've had as a writer
is seeing
my work affect
people both at a screening
of something i wrote that has been made
into a film and then
also even in a table read
um or even just hearing it after the
fact someone read my screenplay and just
talks about not what's good about it or
what's not working but just where they
responded to um
i think that's when i've
gotten the most joy because i think it's
what we're trying to do i think
as a screenwriter you're trying to
affect someone
and when you can do that
in an honest and real way through
a piece of art that you made i think
you've achieved the goal at least in
terms of
the art and on the flip side
the most pain you've had as a writer
the most pain i've had as a writer
are the days that i
didn't write and i have no good reason
that i didn't write feeling like
i should have i planned to put in the
work today
and i didn't and that's going to
uh set me back simply as a
professional that shows up to do the job
that feels tough
looking at yourself in the mirror and
recognize that
there was there was no nobody holding
you back today except for you
and that feeling is tough
were you always that honest with
yourself like knowing
this is more me than well i had this
deadline to meet
and that's pretty self-reflective it's
um
i think i've always been self-reflective
but not always in i think a very honest
way i think i
was interested in a lot of um self-help
books
and stuff to make me a better person a
better writer a better
whatever but i wasn't actually putting
in the work of like kind of
who i am now and
how i tick and and what um gets me going
what turns me off all those sort of
things i never really done the
self-reflection
required for that i was just kind of
taking a lot in externally but not
really doing the internal
digging and it wasn't until a few years
ago
that i realized that and started doing
that
self-reflection and it's tough i think
i think it's necessary to be a great
artist i think you have to do that
especially
if you're putting yourself out on the
page
you have to really understand who you
are
so that you understand what's coming out
and
it's not always the best picture of
yourself the reflection that you see
changes day to day and that has as much
to do with who you are
um inside but also who you are in
what what you're seeing it's it's it's
perception both
inward and outward and um
sometimes when you see that reflection
and you say ah that's
you know you had no good reason to not
work today
on your art that you say you love
so what's what's going on and when
i can't really find an answer that feels
satisfactory it's
probably the most pain i feel as a
writer so do you think you
you feel like you've let yourself down
yeah
and i think that's really that's the
biggest
letdown is that i have let myself down
and everything else
in relation to that i feel like i can
take in
stride if someone doesn't like my work
if someone
doesn't want to produce
my work if someone doesn't want to work
with me
there's always there's always you know
there's someone else
that is involved in that dynamic and so
there's always
something there to say okay well
i i can do all the self-reflection i
want but maybe that's just on them
there's something there and like that
this just isn't going to work out like
for whatever reason if i let that person
down if they let me down there's always
someone else but if it's
when it's you letting yourself down
there's no one else to deflect any of
that
feeling towards uh whether that
deflection is right or wrong
and so you just kind of feel it on both
ends i think because you
you let you let someone down yourself
and you are also let down by someone
yourself so it it
it can be a little isolated
and lonely and painful when that happens
but it's
human i think we all do that and so
i guess i should remember that as well
well that goes back to when we started
out the interview which was just
being in la and traffic and then wanting
to arrive on time
especially if you want to be punctual
and sometimes there's just things just
totally
doesn't matter you could have you know
oh a half hour early i'll be f you know
and some crazy thing happens and there's
a roadblock and
and going back to you feel like you've
you've let yourself and someone else
down but
it's out of your control kind of thing
yeah so it's when
everything when everything is in your
control
and it happens that's when i feel
the pain i keep repeating pain because i
feel like that's
that's okay that was the question makes
me feel it makes it seem more dramatic
but that's when that's when as a writer
it's uh
yeah it's it's it's tough i think
so i mean the way out of that is to show
up and write
so that's what i try to do
i mean i don't know if it's the it's
like the best
story but i do i it's it sticks in my
mind for whatever reason so i guess i'll
share this one but um
i remember i was at a
uh a screenwriter's lab
and we were put into peer groups and we
always
with four people so i'd read three other
scripts and
and the other three had read mine and
then we took turns giving
feedback with each other and it had come
time for mine and um i felt i felt
good about this script it was um so i
was excited for
the feedback and um
two of the people are giving me good
feedback it's really good little little
um really sharp notes really
good helpful stuff and but this other
person is just
kind of silently listening and nodding
and
and so finally it it comes to her to
i'm i'm ready to hear what she's got to
say i feel like she's been pretty quiet
and
and she goes okay so your script takes
place on a farm
and i go yeah she is
have you ever been on a farm
before and i just felt like the wind got
like knocked right out of my sails um
and and we we've become good friends
since we always
talk about the moment and it clearly
affected me more than what she meant it
was
it was a a smaller note then maybe i
took it but it emotionally felt
like it's just like you have no clue
what you're talking like why are you
writing this thing you have no clue what
you're
talking about and the script ultimately
isn't about farming at all so it's
it's not super essential but and i was
able to go back in and sort of
fix some of those things that oh that's
actually not how a farm works or oh
that's actually maybe how crops would be
um but i just do remember that moment of
feeling
like i don't know
what i'm i'm doing
um and to me that that's a moment that i
that sticks out for me as
uh feeling very real in the moment and
the the fear of it's not that i don't
know what i'm talking about
in farming but like i don't know if if
that's then
if that's what she's thinking about then
clearly my this work is just not
there's nothing it must be empty it must
be not resonating with anyone if people
are saying oh that's not how farming
works
and i think about that story often
because
that fear seemed i now realize that fear
wasn't quite uh real
that's just an insecurity that i think
we all have as people sharing our work
and that's something that
will happen and is okay to happen
and you just you learn to live with it
when your work
doesn't even matter if it does or
doesn't resonate with someone if you
feel like it does or doesn't resonate
with someone that's more about you than
anything else and just put that away and
just focus on the work do you now take
that
one instance as it doesn't even matter
what someone says
it's more your your perception of it and
so
even if that person was intending to
take your power away
or even if they just had constructive
criticism but it
you realize now that like maybe there's
like a muscle
and so now it's not as is this you're
not a squeamish
no matter what whatever it's arms
crossed and they're just totally silent
and you're like oh this person's not
buying me at all or but it's you've
become more comfortable
yeah because i i i recognize that that
reaction
is way more about me especially since
i've become friends with a person and
she has been one of the biggest
supporters of both me and specifically
that script
it was actually her like she loved it of
everything that she's read from me
because she's read other stuff since and
that still remains
her favorite and she loved it so much
that she just wanted to talk about these
little specific things about farming
because she
really resonated with something else and
so once i learned all of that
and it just really recontextualized
everything like oh this
this was this is just about me and my
reaction to my insecurity so
[Music]
it's it's fine like the work is is gonna
be
what it is and if i am so
attached to it in that way like i'm only
gonna be feeling that all the time and
that's just i don't wanna be doing that
so just really being like you pour
yourself out on the page
and then you have to kind of separate
yourself from that thing
and that story always reminds me of that
that yes i try to spill my guts on the
page and do something real and truthful
but ultimately that's not me that's
that's the work i could put out at that
time
and if if that's what it is then that's
what it is
that's that's not actually me it feels
like me
but it's not and
i can't live and die off of other
people's reactions to that
so for a new screenwriter who's just
getting their work out and and
hasn't maybe developed that that thick
skin yet
it sounds like they just have to go
through it and it forms on its own
yeah you have to go through it and i
think the quicker you can go through it
just get your stuff in front of people
the more
people can be like tell you this is
terrible
the better off you'll be in the long run
because you will always feel that way
that it's not good enough i think
and the more you just learn to
i think live with that the the better
you'll be
at separating yourself from it